I'm Shannon bream I'm Tom shallou I'm
Maria Bartiromo and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday January 4th 2023 I'm Lisa
Brady DNA leads to a suspect in the
murder of four college students in Idaho
but what about a motive and a murder
weapon if the DNA holds up however they
got it and whatever they did
I would argue that it matters less
because you have this very strong
scientific evidence I'm Dave Anthony
North Korea's leader is vowing to
overwhelmingly beef up his military
after a record year of missile test
launches by 2027 they may have 200
nuclear weapons and they've shown a new
emphasis on producing a new generation
of smaller tactical Warheads potentially
for Battlefield use
I'm Tammy Bruce I've got the final word
on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
nearly seven weeks after four University
of Idaho students were stabbed to death
in an off-campus home stunning The
College Community and the nation a
suspect 28 year old Brian coburger was
arrested on Friday in Pennsylvania where
he was raised and his parents still live
State Police there had been contacted by
the FBI to help with surveillance and
Area 3 Commander Major Christopher Paris
says the arrest was made in
collaboration with Idaho state troopers
it was through this collaboration and
the charges pending in Idaho that those
troopers were able to obtain search
warrants in a fugitive from Justice
warrant that was prepared here in Monroe
County neighbors are describing coburger
as quiet and appearing shy he grew up
mainly in a rural area north of
Allentown before his family moved to
albrightsville near India Mountain Lake
never saw anything suspicious and I mean
I guess that's part of the reason they
hide out here is because it's it's
there's a lot of land a lot of seclusi
more recent neighbors say they rarely
saw coburger who was a graduate student
in Washington State University working
on a PhD in the criminal justice program
and living on the Pullman campus only
about 10 miles from the killings
coburger waived his right to an
extradition Hearing in Pennsylvania
yesterday being sent back to Idaho to
face charges including first degree
murder investigators haven't confirmed
specifics but say DNA evidence helped
lead to his arrest and they recovered a
white Hyundai Elantra the same kind of
car that had been spotted near the crime
scene in November because this became
such a forensic intense investigation
forensic focused including digital
forensics that stuff takes time Paul
Morrow is a former New York City Police
Department inspector the parsing out of
the DNA from the victim's DNA to the
potential perpetrators to find the
foreign DNA isolated then get it
processed then start trying to figure
out how to match it that takes a lot of
time so does digital because the digital
forensics and what I mean by that is
tracking things like cell phone pings
etc those things take legal process and
they very often take a couple of rounds
of legal process so these things all
take time they're not instantaneous
people have to write search warrants and
subpoenas and you know keep the
prosecutors busy all that takes a decent
amount of time and in this case it does
look like that the forensics writ large
are you know what led them to the
accused we have to remember that he's
still the accused um you know innocent
until proven guilty but it looks like
according to the reporting that that's
what happened yeah a lot of questions do
remain about the case but in terms of
the DNA evidence it seems like genealogy
may be a big part of it what was your
first thought when you heard that I mean
it's not the first case where that has
led to a breakthrough or potential
breakthrough recently but it doesn't
seem like something that's done
routinely at this point no it's not it's
actually very much an emerging field and
there's actually been a couple of
missteps there was a famous case a
couple of years ago where somebody was
accused of a rape based on genealogical
evidence and it turned out to be
incorrect it was a false match and he
you know that person was ultimately
exonerated so it's certainly not a
perfect science and you know law tends
to work about 10 years behind science
and Society in general because it takes
a while to get you know laws passed Etc
and this stuff is is no exception so we
are still a little bit in the emerging
era of this we had early uh indications
that there had been defensive wounds Etc
there was going to be some transferal
and such a brutal crime and so DNA was
obviously one of the things that you
know you that came immediately to mind
I held out no hope that there would be a
hit or very little hope that there would
be a hit in the CODIS database my early
supposition was that the best you would
get would be perhaps a relative hit and
then you'd have to try to reverse
engineer it and sometimes those things
end up being blind alleys and let
elaborate on that for me if you would
for anyone who's not familiar with codas
or with this reverse okay so CODIS is
the governmental database of DNA and
what resides in there are perpetrators
who've been arrested for felonies and
who have been swabbed for DNA and then
it goes into the database just like
fingerprints but it's not been around
that long not everybody who is arrested
gets that DNA swab and as a result it's
not very populated as compared to let's
say the fingerprint database the other
thing too is that people get
fingerprinted for all sorts of other
reasons and so getting a CODIS hit is a
lot more of a shot in the dark than
let's say a fingerprint hit would be
which is something that we're all more
familiar with
the genealogical database however is
populated by the the private
genealogical databases and there's a
number of companies that operate in this
space
those are populated by people who want
to find out things like what is my
ancestry and so I was skeptical that
that was going to have a whole lot uh to
do here not because I didn't think that
it would work because as I said there
have been instances where it has worked
but because the private companies
recognize that if the public perceives
they are
part of the law enforcement apparatus
people are going to be a lot less likely
to send in their swabs
but another way around that is to do
apparently what is being reported they
did here which is that they didn't go
with the search warrant and pushed the
sample through the genealogical database
of the private company they posed as
customers
and just sent it in as if they were a
customer to see what hit they got back
so now it comes back reportedly to Brian
kohlberger's father and so now they have
a name
and so now all they have to do is say
okay well do we have a co-burger that
resides in and around the Moscow area
and obviously we know that they did
your next check would be what does he
drive because they'd already had been
sitting on this data point of the white
Elantra and lo and behold he is a white
Elantra okay so play that out they now
have this DNA hit in a genealogical
database
it comes back to this guy coleburger but
the company seems to be indicating on
their website that this is not at the
evidentiary standard so now what does
law enforcement do and by the way this
is all speculation I don't know that's
what they did but this is me reading the
Tea Leaves of what's leaked out now what
you'd be left to do is something called
paralleling which is you'd have to say
okay
we're not going to fully rely for our
probable cause to make the arrest on
what we got back from this database for
us that's just a clue at this point it's
a pointer we got to build our probable
cause another way and that would that
would be obviously better than them
having to rely on the genealogy which as
you say sometimes can be unreliable this
all sounds though like an opening for
the defense team which is already said
you know he looks forward to being
exonerated and these seem like threads
that they could pull
so yeah absolutely and you know we're
going to find out a lot more when he
appears in court so just so people know
procedurally what's going on essentially
what's going to happen is it's going to
appear in court with his defense lawyer
that he's got either hired or that they
appoint for him public defender out in
Idaho and he will be apprised of
officially of the charges against him
and then he will be asked to enter a
plea apparently he's going to enter The
Plea of not guilty but what also was
going to happen when he appears in court
is that the complaint that they used and
that's what it's called out there the
official document is the charging
document now is a complaint is going to
become public under Idaho law that's the
probable cause document that's going to
have the evidence that the police and
the prosecutors judged would be enough
to get them probable cause to arrest
this guy and that's going to become
public and so a lot more of what's on
the table here is going to be apparent
as soon as he appears in that hearing
assuming that you know some kind of DNA
evidence is a big part of that how much
now does determining a motive or finding
the weapon matter does it does it matter
less now or does it matter more to get a
conviction
I would argue if the DNA holds up
however they got it and whatever they
did
I would argue that it matters less
because you have this very strong
scientific evidence and then this era of
the CSI effect if you can go in and show
a jury
that look this is what was under
zannah's fingernails it's this guy's DNA
and there's absolutely no reason she
should have his DNA under her
fingernails and he's never been in that
house before and by the way it's also on
Maddie's hands
um you know it's going to be very very
tough for him to talk his way out of
that now that said obviously you know
the more evidence you have the better
and The Narrative of why he did this
is always going to be important one of
the things that I think many people
don't realize certainly non-prosecutors
don't realize is that a prosecution is
built around a narrative and so if you
have a motive that you can demonstrate
it becomes very integral to the
narrative it becomes comprehensible to a
jury as to why this person did what he
did so that's why motive is important
obviously you want all of these things
but um doesn't mean that you have to
have them and if they never find the
knife and if he'll never give up why he
did what he did and it actually ends up
in trial
I think that you know if they have the
DNA evidence and if they have a few of
these other data points I'm sure that
they're going hard at the interior of
that Elantra you know it still could
definitely be enough
this suspect has been a criminology
student
um are you at all concerned that this
case could lead to some sort of backlash
on this field of study or even an
attempt to you know limit or screen
students in those programs somehow
you know not really I think this is such
an anomaly I know that now you know
people are looking backwards and they're
saying oh the BTK killer was also you
know criminology uh student they uh
Golden State killer it was a former cop
um so you know I think these things are
sort of Flesh and a pen Fascinations I
think it'll uh that aspect of it I think
will come and go
um it is an interesting aspect of it
that he you know was so committed to the
field of criminology that he was getting
his PhD I actually find the subtlety in
there uh you said that I think nobody
seems to be talking of about very much
but this guy is 28 years old and I I
have not seen any reporting that he held
gainful employment
and now he is getting his PhD while
working as a teacher's assistant again
not something that pays very much so my
question is how has he been keeping
heart and soul together how has he been
paying for all of this school
and what has he been doing with his life
because even as a PhD candidate you know
he's not going to graduate with the PHD
arguably until he's leaning on 30. what
has he done in his spare time what are
his interests he doesn't seem to have
any friends he apparently has never had
any sustained relationships so
I that um intrigues me and to be honest
creeps me out a little bit and I suspect
that someplace in Pennsylvania there are
folks in my formal line of business who
are saying to themselves let's start
looking backwards at cases that are
remained unsolved homicides or missings
because
you know you have to ask yourself the
question did he start his career
assuming this is him again you know all
this is predicated on the idea that the
you know the the accused is who is who
did this crime
did he start his career with this stuff
with a quadruple homicide that's a
pretty big jump and so I'm interested in
some of the backstory here that I don't
think has come out yet
chilling former NYPD inspector Paul
Morrow thank you so much for your time
thank you for having me
[Music]
this is Tammy Bruce with your Fox News
commentary coming up
there's been a lot of talk about the
growing threat of nuclear war after
Russia invaded Ukraine last February and
the fighting still ranges on it prompted
President Biden to say at the United
Nations General Assembly no matter what
else is happening in the world
the United States is ready to pursue
critical armed control measures
be one
and must never be fought but Russia is
hardly the only threat there's Iran and
also North Korea its leader Kim Jong-un
warned on New Year's Day he's ordered
his government to overwhelmingly beef up
the military including more nuclear
weapons last year North Korea
implemented a new law authorizing the
use of those bombs for preemptive
strikes as it launched dozens of missile
tests by far a record it's very
dangerous and and has been for some time
Bruce klingner is senior research fellow
for Northeast Asia at the Heritage
Foundation a former CIA Deputy division
chief for Korea by 2027 they may have
200 nuclear weapons and they've shown a
new emphasis on producing a new
generation of smaller tactical Warheads
potentially for Battlefield use and then
in the last several years they've
revealed over a dozen new missile
systems of of all ranges that are all
more capable than the the predecessors
and they have several icbms that they've
demonstrated can could Target the entire
continental United States so the nuclear
and missile forces are very worrisome
they also have a large conventional
force and they're also a very strong
Cyber attack capability uh their refusal
to abide by U.N security Council
resolutions or enter into any form of
dialogue with Washington and its allies
it's all very very worrisome
they've had sanctions on them for a long
time over this nuclear program
but they don't seem to care so they just
keep going on and on and on and all the
ballistic launches they they violate
these U.N sanctions and resolutions so
what can anyone really do well there's
not a lot of optimism left in the room
you know we should keep the door open
for diplomacy as successive
administrations have tried to do North
Korea has been refusing to have any kind
of meeting since about November 2019 or
October 2019.
um so we we need to keep trying on that
um and also we can step up our game on
sanctions there's a lot of
misperceptions of of sanctions but one
problem has been the the U.S through
successive administrations has not even
fully enforced U.S laws we could be
going after Chinese Banks and businesses
to a far greater degree and that can
have an impact on North Korea's programs
not necessarily get them to give them up
but at least it could impede them and it
could alter the behavior of these
Chinese Banks and businesses just one
example is in the past us the U.S
imposed eight to nine billion dollars in
fines on British and French banks for
money laundering for a run so far we've
imposed zero dollars in fines on Chinese
banks for money laundering for North
Korea and that's in the U.S financial
system
now Bruce mentioned 2019 that's the year
after the famous U.S North Korea Summit
president Trump hailed it as a
breakthrough meaning face to face with
leader Kim Jong-un just months after
warning at the United Nations General
Assembly if the U.S has to defend our
allies like South Korea we will have no
choice but to totally destroy North
Korea
Rocket Man
is on a suicide mission for himself
and for his regime
a second Trump Kim Summit fizzled the
president walked away as the nuclear
disarmament and sanctions talks fell
apart that was in February 2019 and
lower level negotiations also went
nowhere after that last meeting in
October 2019 during the Trump
Administration the U.S official said
North Korea wouldn't even Define what
they wanted when they would say what do
you mean by denicorization what do you
mean by a security guarantee what do you
mean by an end of War declaration North
Korea just refused to identify it so
it's really hard to have you know any
kind of diplomatic progress if not only
do they refuse to talk but even when
they do they won't Define what they want
and and diplomacy is each side giving a
list of what they want you try to
negotiate the the linkages but so you
know as they're refusing to talk we just
need to keep enforcing our own laws and
maintaining and increasing our
deterrence capability and and we saw
that during really the second half of
last year when the U.S and South Korea
and Japan resumed large-scale combined
military exercises after a four-year
Hiatus so that was a way of repairing
some of the degradation of our
capabilities and then North Korea showed
that they didn't like that and so then
that was one reason why there's a lot of
missile launches in the second half of
the year because they were trying to
intimidate us to cancel the exercises
that we had just resumed now there's
talk that the U.S and South Korea may be
discussing even allowing South Korea to
be a participant in U.S military
operations in the sense that I mean we
help them with a nuclear umbrella South
Korea does not have a nuclear weapon so
are we going to let South Korea have a
bigger role at the table dealing with
the nukes that we have there's very
little discussion in Washington but
during my recent trips to Seoul it's
quite a big topic of discussion there's
a lot of advocacy for South Korea going
nuclear very high public opinion polls
in favor I think they don't understand
the downsides if they were to go down
that path there's I think some confusion
uh president Yuan of South Korea said
that you know the U.S and South Korea
we're gonna have these joint nuclear
exercises President Biden said no we
aren't so I think as has been in the
case through other South Korean
presidents they may be saying things
that aren't quite true as a way of of
kind of gaining public approval
um so I I don't think it's a good idea
to put Tech nukes back in the peninsula
don't think it's a good idea for South
Korea to go nuclear nuclear sharing is
also a bit Troublesome but I think we
should be more forthcoming in in nuclear
planning or shared nuclear planning uh
more transparency with South Korea and
there's been a
resurrected extended deterrence working
group between the U.S and South Korea
that started last year and I think
that's a good Avenue to try to address
South Korean concerns without them going
down some paths that I don't think would
be good North Korea has not had an
actual nuclear test since 2017.
is one coming
we think so uh you know that said both
Washington and Seoul have said uh all
preparations are complete and a test is
imminent within days and they've been
saying that since March now if all
preparations are complete what that
means is it or should mean a device is
in the tunnel the tunnel has been filled
with with rubble to prevent venting of
radioactive gases and nuclear experts
will say you don't want to leave a
nuclear device in a tunnel for any
length of time so subsequent satellite
imagery showed that the tunnel was not
packed so I I think they must have had
some indication that there was an
intention to do a test uh whether they
had picked a date and then delayed it or
just hadn't picked a date what we're
expecting is not a massive test like
they did back in 2017 which was 10 times
the size of the Hiroshima Nagasaki
Atomic weapons wow uh but but a small
weapon which would show that they have
completed development of this new uh
Battlefield use tactical nuclear weapons
which the those smaller are very
worrisome because it shows yet another
new threat to South Korea as well as U.S
forces and citizens so what is the
difference between you know the big nuke
that we think of that blows up a whole
city or a small Battlefield version
what's the difference
well it could be directed at you know a
tank division or allied forces that are
moving North after repelling a North
Korean Invasion so we're not sure but
they are on short-range missiles so they
could be used as North Korea has
declared they would be for going after
South Korean ports where U.S forces
would be coming in South Korean
airfields that military operations would
be occurring at or U.S forces flowing in
hardened military command headquarters
as well as advancing troops so small but
but still very very deadly does North
Korea really want war we've been
studying this as you said for all these
years do you think they really want War
I I don't think they want or that and
you know some people still think Kim you
know is this crazy little guy and he's
just going to start a war he's not crazy
I mean he's obviously a brutal dictator
but neither he nor his father is
Grandfather or are crazy the the concern
is more that there could be either a
inadvertent escalation or a
mischaracterization of what's happening
so the other concern is is an escalation
where you know a little Clash along the
DMZ gets bigger and bigger and bigger
and eventually turns into a large
military classroom and a nuclear
exchange uh you know that said North
Korea does have a war plan to unite the
peninsula within seven days which means
they would have to go nuclear early as
well as chemical and biological weapons
so they have the capability they have a
declared intention not that we think
they're coming through the wire tonight
but we always have to be very concerned
about that growing capability meanwhile
their people still suffer right I mean
they covered last year
even Kim Jong-un admitted there was a
food crisis last year
conditions in that country are still not
good right I mean it's still dire oh
it's it's awful uh political repression
the people are prevented from having
access to the outside world though
information sort of sneaks in but the
people can be executed simply for
watching South Korean TV shows that are
smuggled in on on thumb drives you know
and often three generations of a family
are punished for the crimes of one and
also the economic conditions are awful
given the Decades of bad socialist
economic planning but also exacerbated
by the basically cutting their country
off from the world for two years and
then also some you know natural
disasters from weather and then the
sanctions have also restricted their
their economic activity but you know by
cutting themselves off even from China
which is accounting for 90 percent of
their their trade you know their their
conditions are very bad and we've seen
indications that the crop Harvest this
year could also be bad do they make
money on cyber attacks is that where
they get all their funding how do they
how do they get the money for all this
well that that has been a new source of
funding and what we've done is is as
we've followed their cyber activity it's
moved from sort of cyber attacks
Espionage you know denial of services uh
you know ransomware Etc the last several
years they've turned first to cyber bank
robbery and then to uh cryptocurrency so
several years ago they they hit the
Central Bank of Bangladesh they got away
with 81 million dollars uh in a bank
robbery they would have gotten a billion
dollars if someone hadn't noticed some
typos in the bank transfers uh including
through the Federal Reserve Bank of New
York and they're probably making about a
billion dollars a year in cyber crime uh
though one wonders what impact the crash
of cryptocurrency has had on them they
probably had a lot of money that they
hadn't converted to real currency yet
Bruce klingner senior research fellow
for Northeast Asia at the heritage
Foundation former deputy division chief
for the CIA for Korea great to talk to
you thank you again well thanks again
for having me
[Music]
and in other news I'm Gianna jalosi
GoFundMe has released his annual
donations report for 2022 listing many
statistics including the most generous
states and cities of the Year topping
the list as the most generous States per
capita Vermont Delaware Maine New
Hampshire West Virginia Pennsylvania
Georgia South Carolina Montana and
Virginia digging even deeper the top
five most generous cities of 2022 were
Marietta Georgia Spring Texas Silver
Spring Maryland Sarasota and Bradenton
Florida filling out the top 10 Olympia
Washington Alpharetta Georgia Miami and
Fort Myers in Florida and Minneapolis
Minnesota the site reports one donation
every second with 28 million people
giving a combined 25 billion dollars in
2022 to non-profits and Charities the
news of the Year also impacting what
people donated towards in 2022 there was
a 110 percent increase in donations
towards baby formula a 6 60 percent
increase in fundraisers for gasoline 10
percent increase in fundraisers for
groceries 2.3 million dollars was raised
for eagle and Girl Scouts projects nine
million dollars raised for various
places of worship 150 000 raised for
veterans 50 million dollars for dogs and
cats 108 million dollars to rebuild
houses after natural disasters and 250
million dollars raised for Ukrainian
relief the most generous day of the year
was May 26th following the school
shooting in Uvalde Texas for the Fox
News rundown I'm Gianna jalosi
[Music]
foreign
Fox News Radio On Demand on the Fox News
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite Fox News talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
Fox News Radio newscasts On Demand Fox
News Radio and the Fox News app download
it today Raiden review the Fox News
rundown on Apple podcasts or wherever
you listen it's time for your Fox News
commentary Tammy Bruce what's on your
mind normally if you design a guide for
your entity and it's based on your
supposed values and it's meant to
improve people's lives you would make
sure the world knows about it and be
proud to share it with everyone Stanford
University however had another idea when
everyone found out that their little
orwellian elimination of harmful
language initiative had developed a
guide of forbidden words Stanford
panicked and locked the censorious
project behind a firewall and began to
Gaslight everyone about what its
intentions were fortunately the Stanford
review the University's Independent
newspaper is filling us all in with the
latest Shenanigans of what used to be a
premier University having slouched
toward woke in the most predictable of
ways in a story titled big brother is
watching you Stanford's new harmful
language guide we are given a peek at
the insanity driving the woke with an
agenda of supposedly eliminating racist
violent and biased words from its I.T
systems and websites instead they
provide the rank absurdity driving
today's woke mob a sampling of the words
and phrases considered too toxic and
damaging to be used include walk-in as
it's insensitive to the disabled so drop
in is to be used instead white paper is
racist and will be replaced with
position paper
Karen will be swapped with demanding or
entitled white person
The Daily Mail tells us It also says it
will swap the term blind review for
anonymous review while tone deaf should
be swapped for unenlightened and
handicapped parking changed to
accessible parking it also States in its
gender-based section that pronouns
should be used instead of preferred
pronouns as the latter implies that
gender identity is a choice the section
on institutionalized racism states that
black mark and black sheep are not used
because of negative connotations to the
color black
I'm not kidding you and now even the
woke term trigger warning is now to
triggering and will be replaced with
content warning
making the most news is the elimination
of the word American to be replaced with
U.S citizen why American quote often
refers to people from the United States
only thereby insinuating that the U.S is
the most important country in the
Americas which is actually made up of 42
countries
you just can't make up this sort of
Madness the mocking and outrage was so
Swift and merciless Stanford's Chief
Information officer issued a classic
backpedaling statement saying they
missed the mark and that the guy does
not represent University policy this
latest iteration of the vandalism of
language started decades ago with the
idiocy of political correctness it is
now part of the bureaucratic agenda
throughout our establishment the tiny
tyrants Among Us also know that if it is
too dangerous and forbidden to use
certain words and phrases we will
eventually stop thinking about things
which require those words to convey our
own assessment of society and culture
and politics we will Retreat as only
silence is safe and that is exactly the
point if the next generation is going to
have any hope of living decent and free
lives and being able to function in
society this circus of the Absurd must
be condemned and stopped Stanford can
issue Mia culpas all they want but
nothing will change Americans everywhere
mocking and denouncing the fools who
implemented this is an important step
but Stanford alumni must get involved
speak up and say enough is enough this
is Tammy Bruce
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcasts
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
precise personal powerful is America's
weather team in the palm of your hands
get Fox weather updates throughout your
busy day every day subscribe and listen
now at foxnewspodcast.com or wherever
you get your podcasts